I work with a company called Coliseum
wrestling and you can like actually
getting to piss off the crowd especially
kids I basically came out and I was like
I don't really get wrestling I'm more a
boxing man myself and I respect all the
greats Jake Paul Logan the crowd melted
down they got so mad and I was like I
got him I got him
[Music]
another episode of trash case I am once
again joined by the boys and we have
another special guest with us do you
want to introduce yourself to the crowd
um hi I'm John I sometimes go by super
eye patch wolf also did you just wake up
yeah so it's got to be like very very
close Wait no that's an awkward hike for
you now now it's like you know it's well
I'll manage
my phone is vibrating for a second let
me be a good let me be a good host here
all right oh yeah are you good yeah I've
turned it off all right yeah do you want
to introduce yourself on what you do to
our audience hi my name is John I run
the channel uh super eye patch wolf and
I've been making video essays about
whatever the [__] for like seven years
that's the best I can describe you
started off with anime and like over the
past couple of years you've kind of
transitioned into just whatever Rabbit
Hole you've managed to find you know
yeah I don't know sometimes I describe
my career as a series of poor decisions
that led places so I don't know for a
while yeah it's been how many years have
we all known each other now it's Pages
yeah quite a while it's been numb
because I remember distinctly the first
time I met you two and you we met at the
Anime Expo like
2017-20 was that the attitude of Meetup
yes yeah I remember that and I remember
you specifically Joey because you come
up to me and you were like hi
you're like really hot
and I still stand by that Tuesday
so yeah we've all been friends for quite
a while uh because I would say we are
some of the ogs now of the anime YouTube
Community I know you hate being called a
nanny tuber now I don't care
yeah I think at this point I've just
given up on trying to Define anything
yeah and I remember back then John just
didn't show his face at all right and I
think it might have been like the first
time I'd seen your face and I'm like no
Annie Trooper should be this hot what
the [__] this is uh because I remember
at that attitude Meetup uh it was like
it was pretty sizable maybe around like
you know 40 50 people I kind of showed
up but it was really funny because I'd
say the majority of the people who were
there were just like all right which
one's super hypertual I have to see his
face and everyone was like yo he's mad
hot that's crazy see like like I didn't
know that that was going to be a thing
at all like I've been with my girlfriend
and wife Michelle for 18 years never
even really like dated around or
anything yeah yeah and so I talk about
doing like a face reveal to my friends
and they're like it's gonna be so funny
and I'm like what do you mean
and so then like I remember I put a Face
Reveal video up and I hit refresh and
there was immediately 70 comments and
the first one was oh no he's hot and the
second one was all capital letters old
and I was like
I was like oh this maybe this was a
mistake yeah
but uh yeah I mean you got your start I
guess
oh God yeah God damn yeah I remember
seeing this and I was like how did your
jawline get better because what the [__]
how does that happen yeah it's great
because I Look At You John I'm like all
right I have I have hope I have hope I
have hope in my life you know you hit
your 30s and you can still learn the son
of guts
[Music]
you started anime YouTube uh for a
pretty interesting reason right because
you did it out of spite oh yeah
completely my entire career is built on
hatred and basically I was like um I was
listening to woolly versus
um and he was talking on podcast about
so I started talking about Hunter Hunter
which for me top three anime of all time
I absolutely [__] love it and hey
I've read it now so oh you've read it
now now I understand good stuff and um
he's like
he's not like
just talking [__] he's going in like
he's like I can't deal with this tedious
Shonen horseshit and I'm like I'm
sitting there at like your average video
game podcast listener just [__]
seething and I'm just like how can you
see that with the anime I like and I
feel like um the healthy thing to do
would have just been to let it go yeah
that is not what I did
um I held on to it for a year and then
made a video called why you should watch
Hunter Hunter not about how he was wrong
because I thought that might be kind of
shitty but just about how I thought it
was good yeah and then also how here was
wrong I don't mean Loki did you mention
it all in the video sorry did you
mention him at all no all right I
thought so no and
um so that was the whole plan you know
that was the whole plan I'm gonna make
this video and then I'm gonna go back to
my actual life I can walk away from this
yeah because and um and then that didn't
happen right and mainly just because
like I really just [__] loved making
videos yeah I remember watching this
video and it came out yeah I was I think
I was around when I binged Hunter Hunter
so it was like kind of perfect time yeah
it was kind of crazy as well because you
almost just like came out of nowhere and
then I feel in a very short span of time
your name was just kind of floating
around in the attitude like whoa where
it's just like this is like new guy who
made this like Hunter Hunter video and
it's like really [__] good and no one
knows where he came from he just like
suddenly popped up yeah and I think a
part of it was like I wasn't on any like
forums or a part of any Community or
stuff like that because people would be
asking me like what's your model list
and all any of that kind of thing
back then oh you like anime give me your
malice
and but I just I [__] loved making
videos you know it just clicked in a way
that nothing else had and like I had
tried so much [__] up to that point you
know I had I like I'd been part of an
electronic like a band I tried to be an
illustrator I tried to be a storyboard
artist I spent six months training as a
wrestler all this kind of stuff and like
it always felt like pushing a boulder
uphill yeah and then when I started
YouTube I was like oh there's something
about this that I get that I don't get
about other things you know that kind of
way one thing so I think when I
discovered your content wasn't actually
the hunter hunter
it was actually the bleach video that
you did uh yes and I got asked we go
through this sorry if you walk me
through this side okay okay so John did
a video basically detailing uh I guess
uh I think the original was like the
fall of bleach correctly yep uh how did
the bleach fandom react to that because
I I wanna I wanna ask about sorry what
fandoms you've pissed off this video is
just you saying that it just fell off
yeah pretty much so originally actually
really positive right I had like kind of
like bleach YouTubers being like Oh it's
cool to see such an interesting like
look and breakdown but unfortunately
what I didn't know over time is like
basically I was basing it all on the
Shonen Jump chapter index long story
short yeah no one [__] knows what's
going on there's no like so I basically
read on a website I think it works like
this and then said in my video it works
like this and that earned me the ire of
the bleach fandom for Ever After yeah 13
000 comments
and the video like it sucked because
like I was really happy of with like the
how that video came together and like
how it told a story it just happens that
the story it was telling was wrong
um and I feel like I have tried to
correct that in various ways over the
years and never been successful so at
some point I'm like okay
I've never seen
it confidently yes because I feel like
the top count is they're proud damaged
people retaliating at anything out of
survival
here's the thing that pisses me off
right right I [__] love
which is awesome like I yeah personally
I think it goes downhill over time I
will take bleach over Demon Slayer over
hero Academia over so much [__] it's
[__] great yeah and the only reason I
talk about it is because I give a [__]
but like look I did get it wrong and
that did piss people off so I don't want
to be dismissive of that you know yeah
because I feel like a rite of passage
with like anyone who does anime content
on YouTube or at least one is like we
talk about anime series is like we at
least piss off one fandom within our
journey right of course uh Joe I think
I've nailed about eight or nine
three
I got yeah I wanted to ask what was like
the fan but Phantom you pissed off the
most and uh we can we can share I guess
so I would say actually probably Dragon
Ball Z really but I just never I've
never made like a negative video about
Dragon Ball Z those guys are just mad
they're angry about a lot of things
honestly probably the bleach fandom
which I mean fair I mean they're still
making Reddit posts in 2022 about why
they're still mad but they're all trying
to collectively figure it out yeah why
are we still mad
I learned early on when I started doing
the like the whole Sebastian thing I I
noticed that like people assumed because
I was making videos on it that I
understood a lot about the show but I
didn't and I realized very quickly that
people care about the show way more than
I ever could and I am never ever gonna
attempt to get to their level I'm just
gonna be the hehe funny videos right
that don't even try to touch it or the
themes because they'll do I remember
people can't be like oh this character
wouldn't say this I'm like I don't care
but she this is the thing where like I
feel like when I started making videos
and definitely like when when like you
start making videos like you could make
a video about you you Haka show and it
would be the video on you you Haka show
yeah yeah now you have channels that are
entirely about one piece channels that
are entirely about bleach Dragon Ball Z
and like it's these guys whole lives
like reading this manga and making
content out of it yeah like fair play to
them like that's that's it it's an
interesting way and there's a lot of
good videos that come from that but I
think then the problem is
when you try and make a video about it
then there is infinitely more knowledge
about it and people who might like know
the series more in depth and have more
understanding yeah but then the problem
that it comes into then is like a lot of
like I guess more casual people are
looking for videos where it's kind of
it's entertaining yeah you know exactly
and it comes into this thing where it's
like you have an audience that wants a
really deep understanding and then you
want a bigger audience that just want to
be entertained yeah and I think the
disparity between those two can lead to
I would say like a bit of bitterness
with creators and like I I get it to a
degree but it's a tricky one yeah I mean
one of my most interesting things are
like I've noticed with like some of my
own content so I found him that I've
pissed off uh is the Fate fandom or I
would say the the only guy talks about
it
uh and it was very interesting because
like I made like a skit just like
basically based around my experiences
whenever I would have a conversation
about the Fate rabbit hole and just like
how how like just one sentence could
just start an entire war in terms like
watch order and stuff like that and when
I released that video it was like
received very very positively everyone
[__] loved it
and then it really started getting
spread around and it started getting
spread around outside just the fake
Community uh and that's when I started
to see people not exactly mad about the
video but mad about people's perception
because of that video that is the exact
same thing it was with me like like I
even went on some calls with some some
bleach guys and it always ended up
ultimately yeah yeah I was like okay
let's hear him and it always ended at
like well I'm not mad at you I'm just
mad at the people who agree with you and
I was like oh okay
oh my God yeah because it's it's so
interesting now because yeah like you
said back then because the anime
Community was much smaller much more as
I would say like inclusive not no no
conclusive is the wrong word but much
more manageable in terms of like what
fans or what now because there are so
many different factions so many
different fandoms a lot of fans get very
protective about this one IP you know
especially at like anime fan doesn't
worry is like too broad an umbrella now
that just didn't exist before you know I
feel like when you're an anime fan
before that kind of encapsulated so much
of the community and now there are just
people who just solely watch One Piece
for example or solely Watch Attack on
Titan or the shonen's I have a fun
question
if you were to do the fall of another
anime today which one would you do the
fall of another anime so like an
animated fell off the real answer is
probably I would not do that
um
one that you felt like you kind of you
know fell out of do you think any anime
has fallen off
no I do not
die I think all anime is great
would you like to hear top 10 facts
about One Piece
you're like man this sucked for years
they hate me I'm like do it again
like I can tell you ones that like I I
fell off one piece but that's not
because I think one piece got worse it's
because I got real busy I didn't have
time to re and like I'm gonna catch up
with it someday and I I bet it's silly
yeah I mean I kind of I never fall out
of one piece I just it just comes in
like waves I there's a wave where I
greet 100 chapters and then I don't read
it for two years and I'm like I I forget
I'm a one-piece fan sometimes yeah and I
read it again I'm like oh yeah I'm
definitely totally yeah do you guys feel
like you're at the point where like even
very milk toasts opinions get like these
crazy reactions like someone will ask me
like what do you think great demons
there and I'm like oh yeah it's all
right and I'll be like
Joey about his tradition opinion I think
we did initially because obviously it
was it was all new but I think now
people are so used to us just saying
dumb [__] that let us write us off right
oh God Joey said it or Connor said it
yeah well I mean the other day when you
know when they announced uh the the new
the title for the new season of Attack
on Titan I quote retweeted and all I
said was this title is really stupid God
the comments were just like how [__]
dare you I can't believe you would say
that how dare you ruin the sanctity of
the final season part three part two you
don't even watch anime anymore you have
no opinion on this and I'm just like
guys I just I just thought it was dumb
but yeah like that's why if I don't
really like something I try not to like
say my like opinion even if I just say
it's all right like even it's all right
he was saying like it's all right it's
like fandoms will jump on you for just
saying you don't think it's really
really good or really really great right
Joey right yeah totally yeah I think uh
one one Infamous trash basically was
when Joey said was like all right or did
you use the word mid I can't remember
okay that was that was the issue that
was funny I'm at this point now where
it's like you know I I obviously try to
avoid you know giving in any like I
guess controversial opinions on like
certain shows but at the same time it's
really funny to piss off anime fans yeah
that's the problem is that I think
people like they hate that yeah I know
but
so mid is such a lazy criticism I agree
I don't like the turn mid just because I
feel like it is a coward term
I agree you say it's [__] or say it's
like [__] so you have to actually like
yeah yeah I'm happy to explain why I
don't like a show I just it might be
[__] stupid is the problem and people
recognize that of me and I'm guilty of
that but I think sometimes like
especially when people are watching you
a lot and people really think they
relate to you they really want to
connect with you on whatever they can
yeah and then it's really disappointing
when they can't like I remember it was
basically a rite of passage in my
Discord for a couple of years for
someone new to come in and be like can't
wait for the boy you should watch hero
Academia video and I just be like I
don't like that show and they'd be like
and then like the other Discord members
would be like yeah yeah we all we all
thought he was gonna be
I always would because like I know the
feeling where it's just like you just
want to make content on stuff you like
and you shouldn't you know healthily you
shouldn't put your opinions on someone
else's opinion you should kind of like
helpfully form your own but there is a
certain sense of satisfaction you get
when you watch a Creator you respect say
that they like a thing that you like
like when when I saw like Charlie
finally get into one piece I was like we
did it boys we did it we did it we
prevailed uh I knew I shouldn't like
have said I have felt that much sense of
Pride but I kind of did yeah yeah it's
like getting your mate into a you know a
show or series you really really like
like have you ever showed a mate like a
or like a first episode of something and
you're just like intently watching them
I don't do that anymore you don't do
that anymore I can't do it it's too it's
too much it's like when you play like
music to someone and it's like the most
it's the longest four minutes of your
life because you're like yeah it's good
right and suddenly it starts to sound
worse it's really good yeah yeah and
suddenly it all starts to sound a little
more uncomfortable
she doesn't sound like this when I
listen to it alone it's just it's kind
of like that so I I normally I'm like
I'm like please watch one episode if you
like it when we watch it again
entirely I'm so done forcing people to
watch this a 30 second beam suddenly
becomes three hours
okay
they ask how long is this again
yeah so you you know you started off
doing anime content when did you decide
uh I want to do some other stuff as well
or was that like always kind of like
something you wanted to do so within the
first year I was I made like a video
about
um Silent Hill 2 which was a big break I
think if you go back and watch that
video I'm nearly like apologizing in it
where I'm like guys I'm so I just swear
to [__] God I'm gonna talk about mums
like a 100 you know
um and I liked it and it was fun like I
remember views wise the video did bad
but I was kind of like it's kind of fun
though you know yeah and then um then
the big one for me is I made a video
about pro wrestling and specifically I
think it was called I think it was
originally called professional wrestling
is fascinating and I changed the name or
something I think it's called Uh pro
wrestling is dumb and beautiful and I
love it or something and um that was
like my favorite video I'd ever made I
was like this is so much fun and like I
got to tell this big story about Kenny
or Megan the golden lovers and all this
kind of stuff and that was the moment I
was like oh I think I just gotta just
gotta do what I want here you know and
yeah because I remember uh when I think
it was maybe like the first or maybe
maybe even the second time I met with
your IRL and we were in uh Dublin with
uh Aki and I remember we were at dinner
and you were like so Joey I need your
opinion on something I'm making this
video about The Simpsons and I'm really
scared to upload it because I feel like
my audience is gonna hate it and you
like gave me kind of the breakdown of it
and I was like no Ricky you should go
for it and then you did upload it and
now it's like your most viewed video oh
it that is my most viewed video still
um until the Garfield video surpasses it
which is going to be anything which is
deeply [__] horrifying yeah stupid
cat takes everything from me
no I mean I think like eight million
views
what God that's crazy that's insane no I
think because like I think one of the
reasons I [__] love your content you
know as a fan and also as resume it's
just like your ability to sell me on any
single [__] Topic at all and get me
invested in it absolutely I'll be real
with you I I never had any interest in
wrestling and after your video I still
have not much interest in wrestling but
it was like you got me invested in
wrestling when I should never have
gotten invest in wrestling in the first
place it is from my own experience as
well for making a wrestling video it is
really hard to sell wrestling to people
who do not have any interest yeah I I
don't know why I just I it was something
that my audience I've never seen the
response to it it wasn't negative but it
was just very unusual I've never had
anything like that if you turn on
wrestling if you turn on the average
wrestling show you're gonna see two
sweaty guys in a ring and the actual
storytelling is not appearance like the
actual cool things about it and then
like the deeper you get into it and all
the great like um I would say getting
Michelle into wrestling was a long-term
project with me for a long time and
about two years ago she said something
that I was just like I did it she just
goes um there's this wrestler called
Brian Dan Nielsen but when he went to
the WWE Vince McMahon changed his name
to Daniel Bryan and Michelle just goes
what is wrong with minstick man and I
was like I got her I got her
bring back the old name so I don't know
like you trained in like wrestling like
before he did YouTube yep uh what like
sparked your interest in wrestling from
the beginning was it something you were
just always into so I don't remember a
point in my life when I wasn't into
wrestling and like when I was little I
loved like Bret Hart and Hulk Hogan Hulk
Hogan much less eventually for many
reasons
more than a few that guy sucks in about
12 different ways but um so then anyway
I um I actually worked this job that I
really really liked and I got fired and
it was like devastating it was like just
this was pre YouTube and it [__]
sucked and I was like okay I thought I
was like kind of following all the right
paths and doing all the right things
like professionally and now I kind of
have nothing and especially like I know
my confidence was super low and I was
like okay [__] it pione this guy what do
you want to pursue like what do you want
to go after and I was like
maybe it could be a wrestler so I looked
it up and there was actually this
wrestling school within like three miles
of my place and then so I just started
training there for like six months and
the only reason I stopped is like a
that [__] is so hard and I say that as
someone who has done like contact
martial arts pretty much my whole life
professional wrestling was like the
toughest training I've ever done damn it
because like with martial arts the
object is to you know the objective is
to not get your head kicked in yeah this
was like no you're gonna get [__]
destroyed yeah
um and so I did that and the only reason
I stopped is because like YouTube
started to kind of become a thing and I
was like I gotta put my whole ass into
one of these things you know yeah so
like that's that's a badass origin story
imagine imagine training to be a
wrestler and then yeah I'm gonna make
anime videos
I mean compared to anyone else I know in
the anime Community
throw in some dude around the ring
thinking of being pissed off for Hunter
Hunter
this episode is sponsored by Bessie
sometimes I get invited to outdoor trips
and I often don't know which shoes to
bring but thanks to vessi's I don't have
to worry about that they are pretty much
perfect in every single season and I've
traveled across Japan and every single
season in Japan with my vessies as any
of you know who watch the show a lot we
all love our vesues and we wear them all
the time and every single picture you'll
see of us in the past year or so will be
wearing vessies and for good reason it's
just an amazing shoe sometimes you've
had those moments where you've just been
caught in a downpour and luckily when
you're wearing bessies it's not a
problem and Messi's new Soho sneakers
are 100 waterproof made with Advanced
Materials and the Dynamics technology
incorporates the latest in Footwear
technology offering breathability while
maintaining its waterproof properties I
love their laceless shoes and I've worn
this one for about two years now and I
can swear by it so there's pretty much
no reason not to grab yourself a pair of
essies today so if you want to keep your
silly Adventures going rain or shine
you've got to get yourself a pair of
essies so don't waste any time go to the
Lincoln description right now or type
invested.com trash taste to get a pair
today back to the episode would you do
any like you know YouTuber like kind of
like sporting or boxing events uh like
becoming a thing now would you ever
consider doing that especially with your
totally kind of like you know I would be
very afraid of your opponent I feel like
you were you have the drive that is
terrifying
if you could make a video like that
about Garfield what could you do if you
actually had to fight what can I do to
the human body I just I just don't want
to know
do you have like a dream entrance you
would make if you like ever did like a
sporting event like that because you
know you you love you love your
wrestling I know I think the problem is
I've had a couple over the years I think
you know what
uh rather than going for like a big
heavy theme song I think it'd be kind of
badass to walk into gut's theme
[Music]
helped me so badass
yeah because like you obviously made a
video you know about berserk as well
would you say like do you have like I
know this is
I [__] question every anime YouTuber
hates but you're on a podcast I got to
ask you do you have like a top five or
like things that like anime that mean
the most to you oh so I think berserk is
like the best story ever yeah
and I read books
I think I think berserk is legit like
the best thing we as a species have done
um I [__] love it so much and but in
terms of like say anime I I could
probably do a top five I think my top
three are like Evangelion Hunter Hunter
you you hack show Cowboy Bebop number
four and I could probably pick something
number five but yeah that'd be kind of
the rough one for me hell yeah
yeah very very respectable list
I forgot what I was gonna say yeah I
said I I gotta ask how the [__] did you
go into Garfield what was all that about
how did that happen
um I don't know because as I explained
in that video I never had any in okay no
actually it was when I think I was like
someone was telling me that there was a
lot of weird Garfield [__] online and
like I love fandom I love people taking
this license and doing cool [__] with it
yeah like I'm just fascinated by that
process I love fanner I like love
anything that's kind of transformative
like that and someone sent me um or
slash I'm sorry John and I was like oh
weird and I was like I should I should I
my thought at the time was like I should
do like a little 20 minute video about
this what is uh what is it I'm sorry
John is like a subreddit of the most
[__] up fan art you can imagine
oh God what is that yeah so yeah it's
it's that
um there's another one called or slash
I'm really sorry John oh my God I really
don't advise people look at that oh god
um and so but like I just became
fascinated with like how did we get to
this point yeah and then like um I
remember I was kind of my mom was asking
me what I'm working on so I'm playing
around with this idea of um of Garfield
and like you know this it this weird
fandom around it and she was like um
as someone who spends a little time on
there rightfully so but um I said to my
mom and she was like oh yeah because you
used to have your your little Garfield
Teddy and I was like no wait what no I
didn't oh no and then and then she was
like Hey did and I was like I think
you're thinking of like my cousin and
then she was like no no you did and then
I was like I [__] didn't and then she
sends me a photo of as a kid holding
this scarf and I'm like what the [__] at
that point it kind of triggered the idea
that like Garfield is this kind of an
Eldritch being really and I it was just
it just became such a fun narrative to
make you know hell yeah yeah because do
you have like a process in terms of like
how you come up with video ideas because
you know it started off with anime and
now it's just like [__] anything you
know yeah like is it just kind of like
when you where you can find like an
interesting story or is that something
that draws you it's just I get an idea
in my head and can't get rid of it and I
think at the point one of my friends are
like would you [__] stop talking
about this that's when it's like I
should probably make a video about this
yeah that's that's actually kind of sick
though that's kind of yeah a lot of it's
really sick like a lot of it's so so
cool because you didn't want a
girlfriend you did one on Sonic as well
if I remember correctly oh yeah yeah
that was a fun one yeah remember the day
I remember
um I was like looking up all parts of
Sonic and there's basically a day I
basically had to go on PornHub and be
like let's see what's on PornHub how
much Sonic porn there is on PornHub
right and then we don't need to search
it out I'm like I'm like looking I'm
like looking at all this stuff and I get
a phone call from my dad yeah and like
my dad will usually call me when I get
something kind of serious like he's the
one who'll be like okay this is like
John listen
this is global pandemic starting and uh
I think we're all probably gonna have to
stay inside for a little while and just
so you know don't go outside and it was
a really harrowing phone call right and
then like I'm like okay cheers dad I
appreciate it and I turn it I hang up
the phone and I turn back to my monitor
and there's a Rouge the Bat sucking
Shadow the Hedgehog sticks
[Laughter]
oh my God Jesus Christ I wonder if I've
ever had that real I'm trying to think
back now if I've had just ever had that
realization about how weird my job is
I've never had that moment where I'm
just searched I mean you you uh do some
weird fandoms one video I found super
fascinating is when you go into like
real life kind of like the you know kind
of like the fake martial arts that was
like one of my favorite ones as well
just because I was I always grew up
watching like a lot of martial arts
films and stuff like that and just
seeing how many like how deep this
Rabbit Hole went it's so weirdly
prolific yeah and the weird thing is
like you would think so for people don't
know it's like basically these people
who think they have magical powers they
got through martial arts and they do
like the no contact chaos and all this
kind of stuff
um but the weird thing it's still
popular like there's people who still
really believe that stuff uh how did you
go about researching a video like that
because that's that's such a yeah where
do you start yeah um I so I I originally
started on this Instagram called mcdojo
right um and the third mcdojo is kind of
like there was a lot of like strip mall
karate dojos like in the 80s who would
just teach whatever the [__] and like
the big trick is like the the Sensei the
master would always be like no I can
never fight you because I would kill you
you know and it's like okay and um so
like I had done martial arts with done
um black belt and Taekwondo I did it for
about 10 years and then um I took up
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu I just love martial
arts I love fighting it's fun and I
started watching these videos and I was
like I was just kind of obsessed with
those like this is [__] insane and I
remember I heard one of these
instructors give this like speech to his
students about how it's very important
that I never fight
because it's that would be like bringing
a gun you know and then like I thought
of it I've been doing Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu a little while at this point and I
thought about how many times my
instructor has just beat this [__] so I
was like well this doesn't really add up
and um it was an interesting video I
remember
um I got
I got an email after that video from I
don't want to say which martial art it
is because then I'll get a bunch of
comments about it but someone claiming
to be a master in a certain martial art
and he was like here's how a fight
between me and you would go and he
explained step by step everything I do
and then he too
it was like four paragraphs and then I
messaged him back being like okay where
do you want to fight okay
give me a time and a place
yeah because that was like the martial
arts and then there was the psychics as
well right oh the psychics yeah yeah
that was actually that was depressing to
make because it just I I took advantage
of people yeah like at the start I was
like this is so silly and then after a
while I was like this is like really
praying on like some of the most sad and
hurt people and so I really wanted to
then I thought okay this video is
actually like I should definitely make
this because it was just really shitty
you know but I feel like that's what
happens with a lot of Internet stuff
like that the fake martial arts and the
influencer video they're all like the
same scam you know it's all finding
these people who really want something
and they don't really have a good grasp
on What's Missing from their own lives
yeah and then taking advantage of it you
know yeah I mean that's kind of how a
lot of Cults prey on like you know
vulnerable individuals who are missing
something in their lives uh because I
did actually because I did watch your so
John made uh a video kind of like going
doing a deep dive into influencer
training courses right yes uh where you
did a bunch of influence courses and you
kind of like tested how effective they
were and I've okay I'm really interested
in that because did you see anything
that as a YouTuber yourself you thought
was like worthwhile advice or was it
mostly just kind of like surface level
[__] uh Ninja told me to dye my hair
um like no like
you you can't possibly give someone the
specific advice they would need in such
a generic way there's no way so you see
I think the problem is like a lot of
these guys they are incentivized to make
you believe something yeah and if you do
not get those results that's proof that
their [__] doesn't work but then like so
then they develop you know like the
grind set like oh it might not happen
straight away but you know you keep at
it and you keep buying these courses and
it's like it's a very Insidious thing I
think I feel like yeah in terms of like
actual advice I got from it I mean I
thought it was all garbage but I do
understand like I'm kind of an outlier
with a lot of YouTube stuff like I think
if you were to give general advice on
YouTube I probably do none of it and
succeed in spite of myself you know I
mean you can only really give generic
advice to a mass audience you can't
really give no because I feel like
everyone's everyone's journey and
everyone's way of approaching it is so
different yeah but there actually was a
really interesting video by I think it
was Ludwig yeah and he was like can I
create a viral video from nothing so not
using any of his audio or anything and
he actually did it and so like there is
like a kind of CounterPoint to something
like that but what I'd say to that is
like is it the one where he sent it to
yes yeah but what I'd say is like yeah
that's Ludwig that is one of the most
like creative and intelligent people in
terms of making content he smokes he
figured out that streamers would watch
videos if it's talking about them yeah
so he just paid a streamer a bunch of
money to get it in front of him and of
course he's going to watch it because
it's like this is why this stream is a
genius yeah which is smart because he
realizes that all streamers have he goes
which is true yeah I mean I I think it's
interesting because uh I do think there
is genuine advice that you can give to
like be more successful on YouTube kind
of Ludwig proved it and I remember I've
seen a video recently of someone who
like tried to make a video to prove him
wrong only for that video to like blow
up so like by taking his advice uh so
you know it generally you do can do
things to like put things in your core
the problem with courses is that by the
time a course is finished uh and like
done it's the in like a lot of the
information is probably out of date you
know yeah because YouTube is like
constantly changing and what is relevant
and what works today it's not going to
work like I think six months down the
line absolutely and it's like there's
not stuff you can't do to improve your
chances like you know yeah develop a
good thumbnail develop like a compelling
title structure your video well so that
people want to keep watching it yeah
like it's not the concept I had a
problem with it's the industry that
built up around it yeah yeah it's like
you're seeing some of the videos like
yourself Health books as well it's the
same kind of industrial you know it's
like you can do it sorry
did you have another point so I know
that was it okay yeah no I I totally
agree I think it's just like the way it
was my like especially some of the
influences I saw in your video is the
way it was marketed to be like you do
this you will be guaranteed to make ten
thousand like dollars or you can you
know and especially seeing some of the
ways that the cost breakdown was like
sold to you that I was like they are
being very generous with their numbers
as someone who works in the industry the
X amount of time if you just do that I
feel like ultimately like the test of
that video that none of them ever took
me up on was just like okay release your
actual success rates don't like cherry
pick one person out of like a thousand
show like the actual rate and I said if
it's over 50 I'll delete the video and I
would 100 would yeah never no one ever
took it off of course
I'd be amazed if it was over like one
percent oh yeah yeah completely yeah
because like the thing about being a
successful YouTube I think it's not just
having like one video that blows up it's
being able to like consistently do that
and that's like the [__] hardest that
is the hardest part I genuinely believe
most people have one viral video I I
generally because everyone has that
thing they love that they probably have
a really really interesting Insight on
it you know yeah I think for me and I'm
probably I consumer you guys as well the
most help I've ever gotten is just from
those camera dudes on YouTube or
lighting people who just give you like
actually to do this put these settings
on your camera I was like that is so
much more helpful than anything else
I've been told because I can you know I
feel like storytelling and that kind of
stuff yes you can be told how to do it
but you really need to actually to do it
and kind of see what they mean like
where you hear all this stuff
you make videos and you kind of get a
feel for that yourself but like actual
technical knowledge that is very helpful
and then like a deep dive into softwares
or stuff that actually just breaks it
down that's all free and available on
YouTube and the best part is is that we
live in an age where if you have a very
very specific problem you can just type
in that exact problem and you will get a
five minute walk through explaining how
to do it totally and that was so much
more helpful than anything I'd ever saw
of make videos you like be positive be
uh promote yourself Channels with like
10 subscribers and a foreign accent you
know yeah
yeah somehow like an Indian tutorial
about explaining some like complex
engineering concept was way better than
any of the lectures
that's not how they do it I was paying
thousands of pounds for that and some
guy ninja did it for free yeah this
episode is sponsored by box who box who
delivers the experience of tasting
authentic Japanese snacks candies and
tea sourced directly from centuries-old
small family businesses right to your
door their mission is to empower Japan's
traditional snack makers by sharing
their authentic food and stories with
the world boxu is a premium Japanese
snack box first Boxer you'll receive is
called The Seasons of Japan think of the
greatest hits of flavors following the
seasons of Japan you'll receive a new
monthly themed box like this one and
this month's theme is Luminous Tokyo
given the Tokyo is Iconic for its
bustling streets with iconic lights and
every single box comes with a cultural
booklet that shows you where your snacks
come from and teaches you more about the
flavors I love my Japanese sembe and in
this box includes mini Curry bread
sembay and oh no it's so good but if
sometimes you get that little sweet
tooth like I do the steamed castella
custard cream is something you're not
going to want to miss out on so what are
you waiting for get your very own box
suit today and get 15 off your very own
boxer Japanese snack box and support our
Channel by using Code trash taste at
foxview.com that's
b-o-k-k-s-u.com that is
b-o-k-k-s-u.com with code trash taste
for 15 off your first order at the
episode one thing I want to ask is uh
every time we hang out especially if
Sydney is here as well you guys always
Bond over like horror movies and horror
media and I'd like so I want to ask you
what do you find the appealing in like
horror movies because I have some I've
been someone who's like never been into
horror movies and I've never understood
Cindy's fascination with it so I thought
I asked you instead okay so there's a
couple of things like once you've seen
enough of any like genre or medium you
start to understand the subtlety to it
and you start to appreciate like this
the little differences between it yeah
but like so like there is that side of
it but a broader side of it like there's
there's two things with horror I think
horror out of any genre is about like
breaking rules and taking down
boundaries so something like Halloween
right it's like this whole society that
is set up to protect you it can't
against this one dude it is like this
nightmare scenario where like you're
[__] you know I'm like there's there's
something to that like I don't know like
just the kind of like
the break of normality but then another
part of it is like when a horror movie
is really well done and really like
scares the [__] out of me yeah
it doesn't matter what's going wrong in
my personal life or the work I'm
stressed out about or like you know this
issue I have with some person or
whatever because in that moment I'm like
this dude's [__] family's been
kidnapped and they're gonna die like it
it replaces whatever anxieties you might
be feeling in normal life you know what
I mean and so I like that there's like a
relief to her right what would you say
then is like the best because I'm kind
of the same way with gone
like yeah what do you think I like some
I guess like if if you were to try and
get someone into horror what would be
some like movies or shows or media yeah
what's the best horror movie for
non-horror Movie watches so I think if
you haven't watched a lot of horror
movies I think slasher movies are
generally a good way to go because
they're kind of like
they're kind of like the the death note
and that like you can show them to
someone normal and they'll get it the
rules are simple and like so something
like starting them off with something
like I think Halloween the original
Halloween still actually kind of rules
right Scream the original scream is
still a really good time yeah and from
there it's like it depends like you know
what the person reacts to the original
like Nightmare on Elm Street like
there's a lot of those kind of old like
Mega Blockbuster ones that are great
yeah because I wouldn't necessarily
start someone off with like The Shining
because like The Shining is just a film
that's trying to [__] you up the entire
way and like it can be kind of upsetting
in that it's like it's like someone
who's not used to spicy food nearly you
know
that's exactly what I am every time
Sydney piss on a horror movie I'm like
Cindy this is way too spicy I said that
and I was like well that's a stupid
[__] announcement I wish I could get
into horror I'm not not afraid of it at
all I just don't I don't know I I never
feel compelled by anything in horrible
horror games
um because that's like kind of a little
bit different right because it's a
you're a little more engaged in this
yeah you can actually find a bit more
engaging yeah because I some sometimes
it's [__] terrified you count fear
and hunger as a horror game uh
uh I think that's just an anxiety
I mean I I think the first time I ever
yeah
I'm scared I'm the most scared I've been
playing a game in a long time but I mean
we can talk about that for like 10 hours
I mean I can so yeah because I think you
got Connor into fear and hunger yeah
your video [__] me up man I'm I'm I'm
so addicted to that game now uh yeah no
I saw your video and there's a lot of
videos that I watch of yours where I
will watch the first two minutes and
I'll be like okay I don't want to watch
the rest I wanna I wanna experience this
thing uh and sometimes I actually forget
to go and experience it so it really
sucks for the YouTube out there
because the YouTubers
you must think like man this guy hates
this video whereas the Garfield one I'm
like I'm never gonna get into Garfield
so I'm gonna watch this whole thing but
like if you're hung him on it was like
two minutes in I was like okay uh I had
a stream that day and I had I had
something else planning I was like oh no
[__] it I'm just gonna I'm gonna bite
the bullet I'm gonna play this game and
I remember when I was told in the
viewers I was like okay guys we're gonna
play this game
um John made a video about it uh and it
seemed [__] up and everyone was like
oh God oh God oh God and then some there
was only like four people because no one
else knew what it was I saw that I
watched that I watched part of that
stream and I saw you being like him wait
there's dicks in it yeah I was like wait
I didn't see that in John's video in two
minutes of that and so I was originally
gonna play It Uncensored until uh people
were like I the people who had played it
were like please play this sensor please
uh and I realized okay well I'm gonna
make this and do a YouTube video so I
should probably play the centered
version uh and immediately I was
terrified just right away because it was
just like
I just immediately I was like oh my God
this is [__] horrifying what do I do
I'm getting [__] by everything and I
don't know where to go and the sounds of
oh The Sounds in that game are just the
worst and this is kind of there's this
track that plays initially and the first
time it plays I feel like it terrifies
everyone and everyone I've watched play
the games the exact same response it's
somewhere that that dooming noise the
booming like kind of uh it's like a bass
that kind of gets louder and louder yeah
yeah initially you feel like something's
about to happen and it never does but it
keeps looping and it's it's horrifying
and not to mention the fact there's
these dogs that chase you initially and
they're the also he needs to [__]
balance the audio on these dogs because
it's so loud these dogs and it's the
most violent crunchy dog sounds it is
horrifying right uh and then you just
get you'd lose to a coin flip and then
you're like
how did you first find fear and hunger
so the first time I ever saw it was like
um I think it was like some guy doing
like monster lore videos on Tick Tock I
couldn't believe this is how you got
into it and um he I can't even remember
which monster he did it on but I was
like
came seems kind of [__] up and then um
I then like a couple of weeks later this
is YouTube I really like called modular
and modular there's like a lot of old
and weird games he did a video on RPG
Maker games and um he had like a little
section on fear and hunger and he's
literally liking it I just want to say
[__] the people who made this game like
he liked it but like he was doing a bit
where he was like what the [__] is wrong
with this game you know and then I was
like oh this uh
yeah say less and then so then like I
played a little bit and then then like I
kind of played about I think 10 hours on
I was like yeah this seems pretty cool
and then like um there was another video
I think by called Oldman TV that went a
little deeper on it and that kind of
convinced me to like get into it
properly and then I was just obsessed
and then I just made it I just made the
video because I was like well here's a
fun way to spend a month playing these
games
Fair what blew my mind most about that
game uh is that it came out in 2018 oh
crazy and it's so terrifying to think
that uh it took five years for this game
to really start getting some serious
traction for sure uh to think about how
many amazing gems out there have just
been lost oh yeah that we will never
ever hear about I feel especially in the
RPG Mega world too yeah there's probably
so many games there are games out there
that would have done like what undertale
did that we just don't even know about
yeah just no one's ever played five
people have played yeah uh and just
because the because I guess sometimes
you just need the right person to see it
to start that Chain Reaction right sure
and it's tough but uh [__] Tick Tock
[__] Tick Tock strikes listen I I
watch too much Tick Tock yeah but it's
like the fascinating thing about that
game is that you played the game and
like you said you get 10 hours and you
have an experience with it and you think
wow okay I've played this game and then
you watch a video and you're like I did
not play this game I had a very
different experience and then you play
it again and you watch a lot of lore and
you think you understand everything and
then suddenly you find more information
out and it can every just everything
keeps changing your complete
understanding of the game uh and it's
really I was saying I was saying to you
the other day that um I think it's
really fortunate that the second game is
already out because I felt that it added
a lot of really cool layers of story to
the world that is already fascinating
and we didn't have to have that whole
thing of what is he making a second one
where's another one coming out I mean
Fair played with that dude who was like
believed in his game enough that even
though like it never blew up huge he had
a second one ready so then when the
first one did blow up yeah yeah it's
crazy I love I loved your your the one
thing that you said that sold me on it
was that it was only popular in Russia
that's how you know it's [__] up I was
like oh it must be messed up
because they only like [__] up [__] uh
and yeah I think I undertale meets
berserk was a great way of explaining it
to some people yeah I mean it wears its
Inspirations very heavily on its sleeve
which some people criticize
um which I think it sometimes can be
valid but I mean I think it's a thing
though like you know when something is
really like reference heavy right like
some people love that and sometimes it's
like
no [__] cares like I get that a
little bit well you played the second
one there's a lot more references in the
second game in the first game yeah and
when you say references well there is
they're just it's it's just children
yeah JoJo's just in the game what uh
yeah I'll show you a picture of this uh
uh okay
uh just like like the model of Johto is
in the game like is he a playable
character or what
okay let me uh this guy this is this is
this is Marco from from uh oh my [__]
god that's jotor and he uses his fists
only
um this is this is him uh oh my God
there's also another character uh
and then there's uh you can type in fear
and hunger Levi uh and uh
you can you can see
holy [__] yeah he looks a little bit
like lero is the obvious one no but this
one's gonna give him the vibe yeah but
like and you know the second game is set
in the terminal Festival a festival uh
that has a moon that comes closer to the
Earth I wish
[Music]
it's crazy because like it does have a
lot of stuff it doesn't feel crazy
though it doesn't feel like anything
else right like it actually does feel
pretty cohesive when you're playing it's
super weird yeah because yeah like that
and then there's also like the uh the
herbs you mix red and blue herbs to make
healing potions like in Resident Evil
and this there's so many things that
feel slightly familiar but it somehow
makes it feel so fitting and it doesn't
it doesn't feel that way at all and Matt
my God is just some of the coolest
[__] law of any game I've ever played
oh yeah really super cool is there any
other like horror movies or things that
have like stood out to you that you've
watched recently
recently
um
man
I watched a film called I think it's
soft and quiet recently and it was like
even by my standards it was like
probably shouldn't have watched that uh
it's it's if I guess if you like extreme
horror it's one of them I don't even
want to get into it but they but yeah
even I have my limits and that was I
felt bad because I was like Michelle do
you wanna watch out and like she's she's
learned to um yeah it's really [__] up
and it deals with some pretty awful [__]
yeah but um it's uh it's an interesting
well I'd never seen that before put it
that way you don't like to dislocation
what do you because you know a lot of
there are a lot of horror movies because
I've seen these YouTube videos that are
like top 10 most extreme horror movies
like horror movies that maybe go a bit
too far how do you as a like what do you
think makes a horror movie that like
how do you like kind of dance that line
I would say like I think the idea of
like extreme horror movies gets like
it's a good way to get clicks and stuff
but what I'd say is like I've been
watching horror movies a long long time
and to me like I don't really give a
[__] if a movie is Extreme I can't like
if it's doing interesting things yeah
because like you can you can make stuff
that's like not that gory and not like
that kind of like bloody or anything
yeah like um like The Shining doesn't
even really have any violence in it
there's no point where anyone hurts
another person in The Shining you know
there's a lot of [__] weird stuff and
like that's the kind of stuff I really
love yeah I mean I think the only one
I've enjoyed recently I don't even know
if this counts as a horror I think it
might be more a thriller but what's it
called again it's like the chef or the
tables
the menu I think the menu
you want to write this movie
because recreating the table
there is a movie called that's probably
why I thought of that no it's not it's
not a horror movie yeah I mean I just
thought it was a really interesting
concept and it's kind of like a satire
on like the fine dining culture and it
was just very well acted you know yeah
it was fun I've noticed that it's been
on every single plane I've ever been on
the menu is on every single viewable
device I don't know why it's much I
think people are just watching it from
there yeah it's really good I mean I
liked it I I wouldn't for me that didn't
feel like horror though in a weird way I
suppose yeah yeah yeah I mean it
definitely I I don't know if it was a
horror or a thriller very because maybe
because it wasn't very gory you know
that's that's to me that's to me it it's
still like not a fan ago it's still like
unnerved me which is what I like with
the types of horror movies I like when
it's like unnerving like same thing it's
gonna say where it's like if it's
interesting it's interesting but like I
wouldn't just like what happened to them
recent recent horror movie I watched I
guess or maybe more of a thriller was um
the new ariaster film Beau is afraid I
haven't seen that yet it's [__] weird
that is like the only thing I've heard
about it is it's weird and it's like
three hours it's yeah it's like two and
a half hours it's one of the weirdest
films I've ever seen But like it's
almost amazing it's it's one of those
films where it's like it completely
depends on the mood where it's like you
could watch it and be like this is just
nonsense horseshit or it could be this
is absolute Masterpiece yeah I've always
preferred horror when it's more of a
kind of human element to it and more of
a kind of relationships and how that
could be construed into horror like the
psychological aspect yeah yeah yeah yeah
one like yeah I'm trying to think of
some examples but I can't off the top of
my head but yeah I much prefer that as
opposed to [__] ghost that uh haunts
you and uh turns you into uh a zombie
there was a ghost with a gun
you like the ones whereas like and
humans were the real monsters
yeah I mean I just like you when it's
like unintentional or like it's like you
know it's just horrific because it's
kind of like wow it's yeah we are kind
of [__] up aren't we we do kind of
occasional [__] up stuff yeah like the
more like believable [__] you mean right
like the Invisible Man I thought was
pretty good I in terms of like the
possessiveness of uh an ex-boyfriend who
is [__] psychotic and yeah how that
could obviously you use the invisible
way as a kind of tool to kind of push it
forward but like you can kind of
understand that it's still pretty scary
if he's not invisible yeah he was
terrifying when he was invisible and the
idea and the thought of and I just I
just loved how it's it's this whole
thing of it's invisible but obviously
the whole the horror behind it is that
he's just so [__] creepy yeah but I
mean that's the thing of it are like you
can like no matter how [__] zany it
can be like someone being invisible you
can ground it in something real and like
that resonates you know yeah I mean like
I think one of I I have like this soft
spot for it's not just horror but just
like low budget films where they have to
like make films with the constraint but
this one happens to be a horror I think
Sydney showed me the invitation I think
where it kind of without spoiling it
kind of details a you know a guy who got
an invitation from a long-lost friend
who yeah this one uh who basically uh is
this the one this might not be the one
actually I don't know maybe I got the
maybe I got the [__] name wrong again
I mean it came out like two years ago so
a year ago sorry so it pretty is okay so
I'm not sure if this is the exact one
but uh it's it's it details like I got
two stars okay okay yeah this uh this
this looks like it's the one actually
yeah
um I it's it deals with a more
psychological aspect of you get an
invitation from someone that you hadn't
heard from for a long time and you can
tell that something is off and you can
tell that something is wrong and then
there will be this point where where the
tension builds up and then like
something snaps and then [__] hits the
fan and I [__] love that so there's
another film called
um
I think it's called all my friends hate
me and it's it's that kind of same thing
but it's basically like the same setup
and it's like this guy shows up to a
mansion with [__] I hope we're not
talking about the same movie and I
haven't got the name wrong
uh yeah that's the one and this guy
shows up to a mansion and there's just
something off about the way his friends
are treating him yeah and it's basically
like the way the way one of my friends
described it was like it's like a social
anxiety horror movie
dude you should check out
so much more interesting then you would
love bows afraid because that is exactly
what that movie there's this bit where
this other guy shows it's like the most
unnerving [__] I've seen in the longest
time this other guy shows up at the at
the mansion and he's like well who's
this guy he was never friends with us
and he says some and the main character
says something about his sister and he
just sees like this new guy take out a
little notepad and write it down and
then put the notepad away and it's like
what the [__] it's great it's really
good do you often find find that horror
sometimes struggles to land an ending
because it's something I always found
that I didn't enjoy with horror films
that often halfway through I feel like
they often lose steam uh when they're
kind of the initial interesting concept
has to be explored more yeah and it kind
of is like I would find that a lot and I
feel like it clashes with this thing in
storytelling where we want explanations
and I think a lot of times horror is
weaker because of explanations yeah
because like the thing about horror is
like a lot of it's like what if this
[__] crazy thing came into your life
and you had to deal with it and if at
the end it's like and then you deal with
it it nearly stops being horror you know
yeah sure I think one of the best
endings to any horror media I've
consumed at least was probably Soma uh
it's a video game yeah oh my God that's
that you can talk about this in a
podcast once as well I think yeah that
ending like [__] me up it was kind of
like it was you know it kind of alluded
to something happening and then it kind
of like flipped it on his head and and
it kind of like that was that ending is
like stuck to me to this day that's yeah
but I know what you're talking about
awesome
wild [__] yeah basically if you haven't
played Soma I hate horror I hate horror
media but Soma is 100 something I would
recommend you guys play yeah yeah but uh
yeah I guess moving on from horror
um so like you seem to have like a very
wide one one thing I've always liked
your content is that you've never really
focused on one thing you've always had
like a wide like intro I don't even know
what your tastes are
like sometimes I try to like narrow down
your tastes and I look at like some of
the stuff that you know jaunders is like
kind of Series where he likes things
I've liked in summer or winter and I'm
like this has no [__] correlation at
all it's the most random assault yeah
yeah
do you do you have a certain like taste
or interest that you can boil it down to
or is it just kind of like no no like I
like
things that I think are interesting but
I I like being that way as well yeah you
know because like I do feel like there
is correlations between things like I've
learned a lot about storytelling through
like professional wrestling you know
I've learned a lot about like I guess
how to structure things from martial
arts and you can take a lot of different
things from all different things but uh
yeah I think it's it's one of the ways
my channel is kind of weird and it's one
of the ways that I should probably never
have survived on YouTube you know what I
mean I I don't agree with that I think I
think people just like having a
consistent voice that they can come back
sure yeah yeah here like a delivery on
something it doesn't always have to be
the same thing I think people just like
having someone inform them because I I
like just learning about stuff that I do
not care about yeah and I think there's
as well like with your channel there's
always that like element of surprise of
like okay
on Garfield from anywhere else you know
what I mean yeah like what's the next
topic going to be and then when they see
something that they just weren't
expecting or they're like well I mean
John made it and it's [__] two hours
long it must be interesting right and
and that's how people get hooked you
know yeah we had this conversation a few
weeks ago on the podcast about martial
arts movies so I thought I asked you
about this uh so like I feel that there
were like way more kind of like The
Prestige of like especially Hong Kong
martial arts film existed back in the
day and I feel like they've kind of
fallen off and we had this theory that
UFC kind of maybe ruined the Mystique of
like martial arts do you think there's
like credit oh I would say there's
definitely there's definitely an element
to that like I think UFC and it was
really interesting because professional
wrestling had to deal with this problem
as well because like oh that's what I'm
fight actually looks like and it's not
beautiful and it's not pretty and 80 of
it 80 of it is two sweaty guys rolling
you know
um and so like yeah I absolutely think
there's something to that but I also
would say in that there is the capacity
for martial arts movies to become the
next thing and they haven't yet right
but like I do think you see it peek
through with stuff like the raid or John
Wick 4 was a [__] incredible movie
was that equilibrium yeah yeah yeah that
was a great film that was fun that was
really important
how do you feel like martial art film
could evolve into like the modern era
because I think it's it's not just UFC
like sometimes I just get recommended of
like you know videos where it's just
like martial artists tries to defend
against like a knife attack and like
showing like the reality of how many
times they would actually get hit and
then you realize there are just some
things that you just can't defend
against so like in a weird way I think
that actually like social media has
become a huge part of martial arts
because you get like a lot of amateur
Fighters now who have like you know they
they're posting their tick tocks and
their daily routines and all that kind
of stuff yeah I'd love to see a movie
kind of based around that but like it's
it's a weird one as well I also think
like with all the [__] that's happening
with like influencer boxing that has
kind of become The Narrative of modern
martial arts you know yeah that's true I
mean okay we've done enough influence
books I want to see more influence of
wrestling now though
I think influence wrestling is very hard
I think wrestling is just super
technical yeah I mean yeah it is even
just trying it for like one hour it was
like try not to hurt yourself challenge
difficult first back bump and you're
like this is what these guys go through
yeah they told me it was soft for them
yeah I was like this is not soft I I
winded myself when I fell and I was like
but you would know that it would just be
a treasure Trove of memes just like fun
like Mr Beast coming in with the
people's elbows
like you've done wrestling training
before what goes into that so like it's
it it is you are working with another
person doing all these like high impact
moves but the thing that like scared me
was the idea I didn't want to [__] up
and hurt the other person right you know
that to me became way scarier than
fighting another person you know because
I was like oh [__] like I don't want to
be responsible for this person's injury
but it's like it's a lot of stuff like
when people get up it's like you always
grab the person's left hand so you have
to you have to be very conscious of like
when I get up my left hand has to be
here and I have to be like telegraphing
this so they know to do that I never got
far enough with it to like speak on it
with any kind of authority so I don't
want to but yeah like it's like Conor
was saying it's this massively technical
thing right because I've noticed that
I've seen some of your posts and you've
done some wrestling events right or when
you come to England you've got like some
like evil Persona yeah yeah
Leslie bestington yeah
um I work with a company called Coliseum
wrestling and um it's fun dude like it
is you look like you're having the time
I I really am like the thing is like you
can like actually getting to piss off
the crowd especially kids because kids
kids can't they like you know the way
kids have the thing where they can't
tell what's real and what is it you can
piss them off so much and they will look
at you with the purest hatred you've
ever seen But like I'd go I'd like I go
up to their parents and I'll be like um
I'm gonna have to ask you to calm your
child down you know
everyone's but um it's so fun as well
because like I got to do a meet and
greet the last time and so I was like
okay what would Leslie bestington do for
a meet and greet so I wrote uh
autographs 400 pounds and I just put it
there and so like these kids came up to
the table and like um I was like hey
what's your name what's your name and I
signed three autographs and I looked at
the dad and I was like 1200 pounds
please
and uh like it it's just it's it's a lot
of fun yeah yeah so what is the
character that you play just kind of
like so if you've seen my influencer
video it's the guy I do at the start of
that Leslie best thing yeah social media
icon yeah and his whole thing is that he
doesn't understand professional
wrestling he thinks he thinks it's silly
so the first time I ever did it
um I basically came out and I was like I
don't really get wrestling I'm more a
boxing man myself and I respect all the
greats Jake Paul Logan the crowd melted
down they got so mad and I was like I
got them I got them
oh wow look at that oh I'm so sick that
looks so fun new followers do you people
have let me let me guess uh six this is
me guessing their followers
what have you done oh buddy you did what
you always do nothing
that's great it's fun did this come from
like how did this start does this come
from like the social media video or did
you yeah I just done that and they got
in contact with me and were like do you
want to do some something and I was like
yeah yes I do and so yeah
yeah
it's it's so interesting when you see
YouTube's kind of just go into a whole
nother realm but obviously you have
history in it but it's kind of cool
seeing it and then seeing you do it yeah
it's been it's been fun it's it's
definitely interesting going into like a
wrestling locker room and you kind of
think you're in shape until like you go
in you're like oh I'm like a a little
boy
yes they are very funny I've done some
wrestling videos as well right uh yeah I
did a video with takeshore who's like
insane now oh yeah yeah he's he's I've
done so well it's so funny because I
when I met up with him he was just
casually telling me about how he's gonna
go to America for a few months and I was
like oh cool cool cool cool I didn't
think anything of it but he was so funny
and so good on camera when I was working
with him uh and then yeah shortly after
I just occasionally every every now and
then I get tweets being like yeah takes
just crushing it yeah yeah like he's not
quite Main Event level yet but he's like
getting there that's right insane your
video was a little more interesting than
my experience because I did it for
Rockies video where she got beat up
right yeah
I put on a logical mask and uh ladybird
clothesline me and uh that was not fun
yeah I I have said this so many times
but I didn't understand that they
actually hit each other uh and so that
when they slapped me with the chalk oh
my chop is just like slapping so much
chest yeah it's a bit different but
they're hitting your chest and they do
it for real and I didn't realize this
because in American ones they do do this
but in Japan they love doing this they
have a thing called Strong Style which
just means we're going to action and
um you know for the video I really
wanted to even though I have like a
blood condition I I was like I don't
tell them that I don't know because I
don't want them to
I was like I actually wanted to get in I
wanted them to like kind of just do it
on me so I was like well [__] it I I
should try it good experience I also
feel like if you're gonna [__] do a
video somewhere you should [__] get
involved like you should actually like
try and do it for as much as you can so
I when I used to train in wrestling I
like got in trouble because one of the
people there she was like like a 14 year
old girl yeah and like we were doing
like the chop Circle which just means
like you have to chop the person next to
you yeah and I was like
because like she was Tiny and she was
like do it do it and I was like and like
I I couldn't do it and then the the
there like my trainer pulled me aside
and he was like listen mate you have to
do it you know it's like I'm like yeah
exactly and like afterwards I apologize
to her but like it was kind of shitty of
me because she's there because she's
cool with that yeah but I think it was
just years of social conditioning where
it's like but I have to hit a woman
when they hit me my God it's like that
scene from one punch man where saitama
uh like like um uh Jenna she signed him
up punching him and he like the [__]
the giant I felt death yeah because he
hit me and I was winded and I was like
holy [__] he's like okay and I'm gonna
do it three more times in a row and I
was like what the next day my chest was
all purple yeah yeah yeah they [__] me
up it was really bad yeah
let me jump on this thing and it was
fine but it was when they made me
he wasn't even jumping it's literally
just falling on your back yeah and it's
still really [__] hurt but Blossom
they were so good and they they really
like had me like that was terrible wow
you know I tried my best yeah but they
yeah they really [__] put me to work
it was really fun I'll never forget it
yeah so someone who only knows wrestling
through your videos what's like the
difference between like different
countries and different leagues uh of
wrestling oh I mean like there's a lot
of different types um American tends to
be like well now you have like WWE and
aw and like but it tends to be like a
little more showy a little more like
thinking about people who aren't into
wrestling like a lot of the times WWE
will try and keep its matches quite kind
of short and snappy aew is a bit more
for hardcore wrestling Japanese
wrestling is like tends to be
there's not a lot of like gimmicks or
like storylines in Japanese wrestling
other than these two men want to be
better than each other and it's kind of
been that like there is exceptions to
that but it's like that is actually to
me the most compelling wrestling just
because
it is how long is uh because how long is
a normal wrestling match then for like
WWE and aw what's like average I'd say
anywhere between seven and 15 minutes
see I I I was watching a 15 minute fight
and I felt like that was very long I
felt like that was just like so what I'd
say it's like an episode like of
anything yeah if it's good it'll fly by
you sure right right what do you
recommend to get someone into wrestling
then where where does where do you
recommend someone would start watch my
videos
I actually hate saying that but my
answer is like watch my videos and if
you see a wrestler you like in those
videos go track down more of their
matches and watch their stuff because
like wrestling at the end they it's a
story about characters and it's a story
about like their long-term Journey over
many years and how that like combines
with their real life and that's
genuinely the advice I give yeah because
one thing I always one thing I found
interesting that you mentioned was like
the like kind of like the separation of
when someone's playing a character and
when someone is like how would you
balance like the character you're
playing and the person that the wrestler
actually is which is a really
interesting part part of the culture of
that where you know with would you say
that
you know would you say that wrestling is
is on the same level as a fictional
story or does part of the appeal come
from not knowing where the separation is
I mean like
if you're really into wrestling the
people who really really love it you are
paying attention to the fiction and the
reality right but the problem like
what's so interesting about it is like
where one starts when you can never
[__] tell right you know and like you
have people who think like everything's
a work we're being set up you know but
then it's like no I think this dude
actually just sucks you know
like it but like that's what's kind of
fascinating about it you know yeah yeah
did you when since you have been
interesting for a long time did you ever
have like you know in school or
something where it's just like oh you
know wrestling's fake no it's fake I
remember like going on a walk with my
Dad yeah and being like
that is wrestling fake
and he just goes odd is John yeah
and I remember just pausing and going
no I don't think it is
why because I used to be into it when I
was a kid and I think that's when I kind
of realized it was fake I kind of felt
like betrayed almost as a kid yeah
because I was so into it it's like
finding out Santa's not really yeah oh
[__] I think it's worse because it just
it felt so real and then I realized as I
got older now I've only really come to
appreciate this in the past year or two
is that no it's I mean from the physical
aspect alone it's so impressive and the
defeats that they're pulling off but
like and then the stories as well yeah
it's like okay you're little and you're
watching it it's like okay Shawn
Michaels and Bret Hart hate each other
and they're gonna fight yeah and then
you learn it's not real and you're like
oh okay Sean Michaels and Bret Hart are
working together to put on what is
basically a very painful choreographed
dance okay yeah but then you get to
layer three and it's like no Shawn
Michaels and Bret Hart do hate each
other and they have to work together to
put on this choreographer that is
wrestling you know like that's what's
[__] interesting about it like I'm
not gonna get into it look up the
Montreal screw job most insane thing to
ever happen crazy
what I want to know are you going to
tell me about it okay give us so
basically I'm sorry to everyone who
likes wrestling has heard this a million
times Bret Hart is the champion he's
about to leave the company and he's
refusing to lose to Sean Michaels he's
like I'm not going to do this because I
[__] hate this guy so much they have
to put on this Main Event show together
and so they arrange the whole match Bret
Hart's gonna win or it's gonna be a draw
or something and there's going to be a
bit where Shawn Michaels puts Bret Hart
in his own finishing move the
Sharpshooter and to Bret Hart he's gonna
reverse it and tap Sean Michaels out and
that's going to be the end of the match
however before that happens they ring
the bell to make it look like Bret Hart
Tapped Out
oh okay and you can see he's like what
the [__] that wasn't how this is meant
to go he spits on the owner of the
company it's this giant like disgrace
and like basically backstage goes insane
and it's it's just this weird like
blending of reality and like you know so
there's people who would be like this
that was all that was all set up I don't
think it was
that's that that's really cool yeah it's
really [__] interesting to hear more
about it in my video
villains of wrestling I don't know if I
even said the right videos
I think so yeah yeah
but uh you not only have done wrestling
on YouTube now you've uh branched out
into much as well that's really cool
hearing you kind of talk about this like
are you two years ago or a year and a
half ago yeah yeah with a call and you
were like I'm really excited about this
merch stuff and I was like dude it
sounds sick you tell me about you
building like a whole world around it I
was like that's man we just put I'll put
a logo on stuff well I mean like I did
that as well before
um but yeah I so like with the merch
stuff like I'd have to give like a lot
of credit to otaku versus who kind of
like he sort of talks me because I
basically like I wanted to do merch
stuff and I was like I don't know what
the [__] to do you know yeah and I got
talking to him and like hearing like his
like explanation of everything and like
what it kind of was it really um it
really opens me up to it's like man okay
so I basically like I think like a lot
of people when I was like younger I had
this like story or like I wanted to make
and at different times it was like a
comic book a series of videos a video
game and I was like okay yeah you know I
wanna I wanna do this thing and
um then eventually I was like okay what
am I gonna do with this one it's like
what if I made like a fake anime and
pretend that it was real and made merch
out of that and it pretty much just
started from there um my work started
it's such a sick concept but yeah yeah
there's been other stuff like gorillas
is kind of similar-ish you know and so
like I don't want to take like credit
for that necessarily but um and like I
was working on it and then like I was I
just explained it to one of my friends
Rebecca brobeck's on Twitter and she was
like yeah I'll give you a hand with that
and she started doing concept art for it
and like the day I sent her the
descriptions for the characters and she
sent me back the concept for the
characters I was just like oh [__] like
this could actually be so legit and it
was it was so fun to work on yeah and
like it's done well and people are into
it and like you know financially it's
been like viable which is great and all
that kind of stuff but I think it's
actually something that really kind of
it made me kind of fall back in love
with like content creation and doing
stuff like that because it added this
whole other thing to it and it's been
really really fun and like right now I'm
working on the third run of it which is
like everyone is like a new arc in this
fake anime and this is like the arc or
like the villain gets introduced and
like I'm so [__] hell you know I I
never know how I was gonna go but like I
I I've been so excited about it so to
explain your Concept in case you guys
aren't familiar you kind of like telling
a story through your merch yeah right
that's so cool built an entire world
around it with characters how long okay
I got asked how long did it take you
from like you said you had an idea of
like stories you wanted to tell how long
did it take you to actually flesh out a
world and a story that you wanted to
tell so from the point where like I
started doing it I think to like the
point where it's like it actually we
have a t-shirt design I think that was
about nine months and like a lot of we
basically every with the runs we do like
a kind of um we do like a little Zine of
all the concept work and all the [__]
that never even makes it into the actual
merch you know like the kind of
supplementary characters and like the
world and how it all works and
um so we basically just spent like nine
months building all that stuff up like
whenever I do it whenever I think up a
new character or something like that I
write down who the character is what
their place in the story is and then
their relationship to every other
character right and that's all [__] that
like that's never gonna make it into a
t-shirt or sometimes it does it in weird
ways but it's the kind of thing where
like
I always feel like when you're watching
a show you can always get a sense for
when someone has thought about like
every part of this world and when
someone is like
kind of making it up as they go along
and I really wanted to feel like the
former Yeah because sometimes you know
you it's that's why I like World
building because sometimes you watch a
show and it feels like the world is
built around this one character and the
ones the stories I feel are truly
magical is when this is when you know
you turn off the episode or you close
the book and you feel like the world is
still taking place the story is still
continuing on right yeah yes it's still
continuing on even if you're like you're
you are not actively taking apart in it
um and the fact that you've just put
that into your merch is like insane well
I think it's like it's that kind of
thing earlier where I was saying like
having like a lot of interests really
can feed into different things in
different ways because like one of the
biggest Inspirations from it was um the
York New City Arc from Hunter Hunter
which is just this [__] insane just
like chain reactions of events yeah to
the point you get to the end of it it's
like what happens and it's like I don't
[__] know
and like it's so chaotic and insane and
it has like insane anti-climaxes and
everything yeah but because Takashi has
like thought of that these characters so
much it all works and it's so compelling
and I love that idea you know and I was
like I want to make a t-shirt here you
know yeah like that's kind of like what
some of my favorite moments like one
piece isn't like the actual Arc it's
when like the arc ends and then it like
kind of like you you get a hint about
what else has been going on in the world
I mean while right yeah yeah pretty well
and then you realize holy [__] people
are fighting [__] Wars and Luffy is
just like chilling on this island one
particular part and it's when I think
they get back from the sky islands right
and it just there's like an episode or
two which is just all the chain
reactions that have been happening and
oh I remember seeing that for the first
time being like oh [__] this is insane
you know for sure it's it's it's like
you know you kind of realize oh maybe
Luffy isn't the main character for like
a moment right yeah yeah that's like one
piece is like [__] third two main
characters and uh everyone's just like
doing their own things that's just
that's just what I love about one piece
I guess absolutely so whenever you guys
mention me on this podcast yeah I get
a flood of messages
it's always interesting because and I
remember one of the ones Grant was your
story about someone Miss thinking we're
the same person or thinking one of my
videos was your videos and you getting
into it like and arguments on that
behalf but um I always think it's really
funny when that happens and there was
one story I had that I just loved and I
think I might have told you guys this
before right
um
but it was a guy uh magfest and you just
it was just a regular meet and greet and
you know he'd been killing for like an
hour or something and then he's like um
I really loved your videos on Legend of
the galactic heroes did I tell you this
I remember this story did I tell you
Connor okay so um I'm like oh
I don't think that was me and he's real
adamant he's like no no it was and I was
like I it's not because I've never
watched that show I'm sure and so like
I'm doubling down and he's doubling down
and but then I say that and I just see
him like collapse and he's like oh no oh
no no no I'm like that's what he starts
saying like he's really I'm like who
it's not a big deal like who cares you
know
um and then he's like I'm so sorry and I
have to be like no me it's all right
it's fine it's fine like it it really it
doesn't matter you know and So
eventually he recovers and he just goes
okay
I just want to say
I really love your what's in an OP
series
which is also not for you no that that
is uh that is just two mother's basement
another yeah
um and so I'm just I'm just standing
there and I I just I just go
thanks man
my favorite part of the whole thing is
later on he spots me at the con and he's
like he brings his friend over and he's
like this is the guy I'm like hey Jeff
too
it's nice to meet you
have you guys ever had stuff like that
oh all the time every other day so
um me and Joey get like people like
confuse us all the [__] time really
yeah so many times in fact it uh like it
most recently happens at uh Gamescom
when I was filming uh an official video
for uh like a new verse game
um the guy running the booth comes up to
me and goes oh yeah you are working with
us today I'm like yeah I was like oh I
love your stuff the anime man
that sounds like such an unnatural
weighted like I Love You full screen I
was like oh are you are you the enemy
man are you here to work with us and I'm
just like ah I'm not the anime man but I
am here to work with you yeah my other
favorite one with uh gone and I was uh
in Singapore uh AFA which was like back
in like 2017 or something and I I was
guessing there and because you know gone
at the time was still living in Thailand
he was like oh yeah I'll pop over and
you know come hang out with you guys so
gone now we're just walking around uh at
the convention this dude far off in the
convention just like eyes me directly
and I'm like okay that's probably a fan
so I'm waiting for him to come over he
comes over to me and has the biggest
[__] happy face and he just goes oh
my God I love you
meanwhile God Is Standing
I just felt so bad just being like
this weird thing that happens when you
show your face a lot online where people
recognize you and they can they can
recognize you but they can never tell
you like where they recognize you from
yeah yeah and that one's always the
weird one but I've also heard that I I
started doing this because I heard some
other people were doing this too where
someone be like I'm a huge fan and then
you'd you would proceed to go name one
of my videos or name something oh you're
a fan name five sea dog videos I was
like I was curious one time and I was
like oh yeah which one
and they name one of Joey's videos
what's scary about this is this is
probably actually really common and we
just never asked probably yeah yeah
because you've probably never asked
people and they'd probably be like I'm a
huge fan and they probably they pretty
just I mean it's it's listen I don't
need someone to justify being a huge fan
if you're gonna approach Conor you
better have your friends no but just
don't say I'm don't specifically say I
am a huge fan if you are not a huge fan
I'm not gonna ask most of the time like
yeah whatever and like I'd say like you
shouldn't you only ever tell the weird
stories right because like like 99 of
people
even I remember like the first fan I
ever met was still one of the strangest
interactions I had I can't remember if
I've told you this because you guys are
not this was like very shortly after
like my my face reveal a guy came up to
me and he was like um super I watch Wolf
and I was like oh that is the name of my
YouTube channel I I I had no like flow
where I had no idea how to handle this
interaction and then he goes oh man I
love your videos and it kind of goes
just so you know I'm straight which
immediately I was like
and then he just goes and like he says
it's so casually he just goes but I'll
suck your dick
he said it in a way that was really just
like this is not a weird thing to say at
all right and so I I just kind of went
like
well good to know uh I'm cool but thank
you for watching my videos
I just like you have something like the
wildest stories of like some fans
considering you do like just like video
essays you know like I can like I've
seen obviously you know with some people
who show their face a lot and do kind of
like maybe content like ours where you
get like a relationship or like a
parasaur social relationship
um but you you just you just [__]
started talking about anime making like
cool interesting stuff and uh you have
some wild stories sometimes which is why
I was very surprised when you went to ax
this year you did not like you you just
went you just did like a meet and greet
in public it had been like three
pandemic since the last time I'd done
that and I thought like this will go
fine yeah and it was [__] not [__]
immediately and then immediately and
then it was a fire hazard immediate it
was I I felt so bad because I was like I
said but I think think the lesson there
is don't [__] do that yeah because I
remember like we had our wake-up call in
MCM uh oh yeah yeah because you never
want to like admit that you got to be
like no I need people to manage like yes
we don't need security yeah I don't need
like like I don't need security I don't
need people to manage my fans yeah like
I'm one of them yeah you never want to
admit that you've gotten to the point
where you're like oh [__] this is uh
Beyond My Control now yeah and like I
think even on my way to that Meetup I
was like something doesn't feel right
here like this is this might be a bad
idea how many people showed up so it
like I I don't know because the first
one was shut down immediately I didn't
even get there and so then we had to
move it to a second place and people
started showing up and it wasn't even
that many people uh but like one of the
con workers were like what the [__] is
this and then I just moved and then had
to move to a third and like by that
point there weren't that many people
because it was just like I think I think
exactly yeah well it's just a treasure
hunt at that point yeah yeah I've
noticed you've been showing your face
more often as well
yeah I kind of just there's more you can
do and there's more jokes you can make
like sometimes I write a joke and I'm
like this will be funnier if you can see
my face yeah you know but um I think
part of that is just like I just
I like trying new [__] you know and I
like I like just kind of disrespectful
if I but if I don't do that I'll get
bored and I've always felt like the
biggest danger to my channel like it's
not it's not YouTube or it's it's not
like you know just weird [__] you can't
control it's me losing interest and so I
have to do my best to keep it
interesting for me which is why the
topics I do tend to kind of vary so much
yeah it's that fear of like getting into
a routine right that's like that's why I
stopped making the why you should watch
videos that I used to make because I was
like it got to a point where it felt
like I could pull some levers and [__]
out of the video and I hated that you
know what I mean everything's gonna be a
struggle yeah yeah if I'm not in some
amount of pain I'm not doing it right
what do you think about this new like
current trend of just video essays okay
so you may you've made some long video
essays before right I can't imagine how
much work they take but I've noticed a
trend where video essays have just
gotten longer and longer to the point
where it's just like now we have have
like a four hour video essay
what do you mean it's like there's like
eight hours yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and yeah it's a lot dude I watched
the six and a half hour talking Mickey
Memorial breakdown video which is like
one of the best it was amazing it was so
good incredible I don't even know what
that is but I'm willing to give it six
and a half hours because if someone is
that passionate about a topic that
they're willing to do six and a half
hours of editing then I'm I will watch
it it's very action button
um and that's the guy mix that's called
Tim Rogers and he's been a journalist
for like ever so like he really knows
his [__] and he is really knowledgeable
and he's the perfect kind of person to
make a video like that he's also just
really [__] funny and stuff yeah I
hate that guy
just watch his videos I'm like God
in terms of like the the like larger
Trend to be honest with you like
I'm never gonna make an eight hour video
but hell if someone can do it and keep
it compelling more power to them like
I'm sure that's a lot of I don't know I
didn't know someone could make a
two-hour Garfield video but I mean like
you know I'm sure there's a lot of bad
eight hour videos I'm sure there's a lot
of one hour bad one hour videos I've
probably made some of them you know it's
like bleach fans be like oh well
actually
yeah but I think um it's very easy with
YouTube to get caught up on what other
people are doing and I think ultimately
like the healthiest thing is if there
are just lots of different videos being
made in lots of different ways and
lengths and styles and like they're not
all gonna be for you but they don't have
to be yeah it used to be that like you
mentioned earlier like if you made a
bleach video or you made a anime video
about it you were normally the one video
and it's kind of getting it kind of used
to be like that generally about a topic
but now when there's like a kind of a
cult game or a cult kind of piece of
media everyone's kind of scrambling to
to make a a long form essay video about
it does anything you ever like have to
consider or if someone else makes a
video you're like ah I can't make my
video no because I feel like if I really
make a video right no one else would
have made that video the way I would
have made it yeah you know because like
I'm never gonna do like uh review of
Starfield because I don't [__] care
it's like I'm never gonna make a video I
don't really give a [__] about it and if
I really give a [__] about something
it's not going to be like anyone else's
and that's that's not unique to me
that's like anyone who's really gonna
put their own individual take on a video
yeah absolutely I mean sometimes you've
made a video I'm like [__] John can do
it better than any like than I ever
could I can never make it yeah your
Bucky video I'm like well [__] I can
never make a Bucky video again
so well though man yeah but but like I
did it well because you're watching the
end product of what I did if that went
through your pipeline and your PR dude
that video would be [__] hilarious
what are you talking make a Bucky video
shut the [__] up
fans of each other yeah
no I just want to see you make a bakkie
video no that's why he's the goat man
has he ever been someone in who is in
your community who has just been
extremely persistent in emailing you to
make a video about one topic and has not
given up oh constantly yeah and on I
like there's one guy
and I think it's
it's like this this Lego thing I think
it's called zoids yeah I've been getting
emails from him for about six years
[Laughter]
and I'm like I never know what's avoids
video from you would be [__] old I
don't know anything about it and I just
look it up and I'm like what the [__]
and he's real but like the thing I
always say is do you know who should
make a video about that him yeah and it
would probably rule yeah yeah you know
if he took a fraction of the time he
spends writing me emails and made a
video about it it'd probably be class
you know that's you know you brought up
a very interesting point with how you
started YouTube which is if we've said
anything to piss you off in our videos
like it let it cook and then just do it
John and just make a video make a video
yeah man make a career out of it you
know end up on an extremely successful
podcast
no do you do you ever Miss like old
Annie tube like no
um I mean I feel like any tube there is
because our audience is so new and so
yeah different I feel like it it doesn't
hold the same weight I think that it
doesn't know to you that it might have
to deal with I mean any tube for a time
was actually a genuinely I think really
special interesting thing and like you
know a lot of great videos came out
about that and like it did really deepen
a lot of my understanding about anime
and like just how to appreciate media in
general yeah it's also just a lot of
[__] yeah a lot of petty [__]
yeah that's just a lot of like well I
think this and it's like okay that's
cool and then it's like well no argue
with me
the whole Space is matured right yeah I
think so that's when people start making
their livelihood on it you're like
actually no I I don't want to ruin
Someone's Child yeah or get in fights
with people I feel like it's I just want
to work and like it does get to the
point as well though where like it is
hard to deal with any kind of like um
conflict in a fair way because I don't
know if you ever have the thing where
like someone will like I don't know say
something dumb on Twitter and then
you'll be like you'll you Tweet back and
you're like listen mate you're being
silly and then every then like 40 people
who follow you are like yeah he's right
you're being silly and you should
[__] die that's like well now I
didn't say that you know you're really
paraphrasing yeah no yeah that's why you
know sometimes you get a comment you're
like I want to respond to you yeah maybe
that's why some people have alt accounts
you know so so because like World count
is weak sorry it's weak to have an
altercare yeah but sometimes I just want
this person to know that I disagree with
him without millions of like my like it
almost feels like when I have like
followers that back me up I'm like guys
I don't need your help I got this okay I
got this okay don't don't worry don't
worry there's always going to be that
the your platform and size behind it
there regardless no exactly
I I have like responded to people like a
bunch of times and like more than I
should have and every time I always
think it's gonna feel great it always
feels just bad yeah
there's that instinct you know where you
just see like a really [__] take and you
can just feel the vein in your forehead
thickening yeah
the fury comes like a clever comments
there's five minutes where you've
drafted the Tweet but you don't post it
on the most powerful this powerful
mental
a wrestler who I think has found this
really beautiful solution to this
whenever anyone talks [__] to him on
Twitter he goes on their profile he
finds a picture of them he copy and
paste the picture and just replies with
that
that's so cruel
oh
this year this is often the people who
have like the most weirdest uh fetish
porn [__] on their account that took the
maddest [__] of course yeah uh yeah I
remember a guy tweeted something at me
that was rather insulting and I was like
who the [__] is this guy I click on his
profile and it was like it was like
inflation porn only and I was like what
the [__]
it's just this guy you're dealing with a
man who has nothing to lose
I mean it's it's a meme but it is always
the anime profile pictures as well it's
the Kyoto animation profile pictures oh
it's you know you know that's all too
well John I'm getting [__] Warframe
never understood the the like overlap
there just these really positive anime
about these girls learning to play music
and befriend each other it's just most
insane people you will ever meet yeah I
love it and you know you can always tell
when you piss off like a fandom because
you know it I I just there's just some
sort of irony in here where it's just a
person criticizing you for you know
talking about bleach or something and
it's just like the the most obvious
bleach fan accounts who just like goes
home sleeps worships Kubo yeah I
remember one time the best the best
example of this I've ever gotten was
someone got really mad at my shenmue 3
video yeah
and um
I think so and uh critical consensus was
that it's bad yeah yeah but you know
that what are the critics look if
someone if someone is not like
d-legitimate for liking that yeah I'm
not saying that but this person they had
shenmue in the title up there
thumbnail with the kill but I I um
responded back to them just being like
okay person with shenmue in their tag
but then when I looked at their profile
picture
them with
um the it was them with you Suzuki the
maker of shenmue so this person I think
it's you Suzuki maybe I'm [__] that
up no it is and it was so like actually
yeah like it was them at a fan meet and
greet with that person
and
look back illusion yeah yeah but you're
never gonna change that man's mind
was it ever a a video you started making
and thought no I just can't I can't I
can't finish this one or that you just
didn't you scrapped it for once my
second video ever and that's the only
time it's happened I am I done the
hunter hunter video and I was like okay
now I'll make it and I didn't really
talk about kilo in the hunter hunter
video we've never [__] love that
character and I was like okay cool I'll
make a Kahlua video because you know
I've already recently you know reread
and rewatched a bunch of Hunter Hunter
and like it'll you know everyone who
already likes Hunter Hunter will watch
this video then like that'll work yeah
yeah and then I was like
but I don't want to
and then I was like and I also I don't
want to be like the hunter hunter guy
yeah and I was like I think I'm more
excited to make a different video and
then I made a different video
and that's kind of been my whole career
what's the video you've spent the most
time on because like like even for me
doing a half hour video is just I I
dread it sometimes just like even the
half hour run time I'm like this is so
much [__] work you've done like hour
two hour videos I would say probably the
two hour video
um so I had two two-hour videos one was
the unreality of pro wrestling which is
relatively recent right and or maybe
that was an hour and a half I can't
remember but the probably the biggest
one was what you should still read
berserk which was an absolute [__]
journey to make that video yeah yeah
because there are there are some shows
where I want to make a video on but I
just like I I sit down just like try and
start writing the script and I'm like I
don't know if I can do this Justice you
know some like you know I'm sure people
will think I do it justice but I you
know proving it to myself that I can but
if you weren't a little bit afraid
like I I have to be I have to feel that
to make a video you know like I I like
that like [__] I don't know if I can
pull this off like that that will make
me make a video because you just you
just gotta ride the fear guarantee yeah
no I've done that a few times but it's
just like it's been one of those videos
where I've started I write a sentence
and then it's like a year-long process
of me like psyching myself up to do this
and then I do it and then I'm like okay
that was great and then I'm like
but I gotta do it again baby
that's me with this [__] oyster video
I've been trying for like four years and
I just like I just can't every time I
rewrite or reread the script I'm just
like it's not good enough yeah and and I
think it's just because like it's such
an important series for me well it's a
difficult one to write about a difficult
one to write about too especially
without like giving away spoilers and
stuff like that you know so it's just
like I've just been sitting on this
video for like four years I still get
people coming up to me every now and
then being like
Yeah Yeah because sometimes you know
something just happens and something
doesn't pan out yeah other people are
really excited about it and I'm like
[__] I shouldn't have said it yeah and
like or I could or I could just
pleasantly surprise them when it comes
out yeah that's why I've stopped that's
why I've stopped doing that as well yeah
you know it'll come out when it will
come out and uh if we've got to cook we
don't even tell them it exists yeah yeah
yeah it comes out it comes out
so
on that topic is there anything you want
to do that you haven't been able to do
on YouTube yet or anything like any
dreams that you want to do so
yeah there's there's some stuff
[Music]
um
I really want to do a video on the movie
Jingle All The Way
Arnold Schwarzenegger Christmas movie
and legitimately one of the greatest
movies of all time
I love the length so they go to in that
film you get a [__] toy yeah it is a
good movie actually I think I've
rewatched that recently yeah I I I've
rewatched it recently every year for 30
years
um
okay we can't put that on there
yeah
wow he really does have shenmue in his
name yeah
um yeah that is an amazing film and then
I also made I think probably the most
unhinged video I ever made was called
Space Jam 2 is a life oh my God I love
that I am and
I have a video that is a sequel to that
video but when you click on the video
you won't know it's a sequel to the
Space Jam 2 video until like 40 minutes
in and that to me would be
like so [__] weird and it makes me so
excited to do it but it's like it's kind
of the things yeah it would be
um and I'd love that because I know a
certain percentage of my audience would
[__] hate it that always makes me
pretty excited yeah you're just like at
some point I think you're like the most
eloquent [__] anime essay so [__]
just a video SAS on the [__] YouTube
and sometimes I just think you're a
massive Troll and I can't decide which
which side of the fence you are I I
don't know I have a question where did
you get your narrating style from it's a
really boring story but like so I
started doing YouTube and
um I just didn't know how to talk and so
it's just it's just real monotone but
then I started getting comments from
people who
English wasn't their first language and
particularly people who English wasn't
their first language who had learned
English in like America right and they
were saying that like I can't really
understand you a lot of the time could
you slow down and so I started slowing
down but then like when I started
talking slower my voice kind of dropped
an octave and then that kind of became
like this and it just naturally went
that way and it's weird because like
sometimes like whenever I see like one
of my videos Pierce like outside my
bubble yeah I get some I see so many
people being like why does he talk like
that you know and
um like Joey I saw you recently or not
recently but I got sent the clip of you
saying that I talked too slowly in
videos and that you speed up my but but
no no no no no no no
okay because sometimes I'm just like all
right I really want to know what John's
gonna say on this topic but I know the
speed at which super high pressure
and sometimes I don't have two hours to
kill so I'm just like sorry John I'm
gonna up it just a tiny little see Joey
I know that you do that now so I've been
narrating all my videos at 0.75
God damn I think think like ultimately
at the end of the day it's the way I
like to narrate videos and like I get
it's not for everyone that's cool but
like I don't know if you guys can tell
from my videos I stopped trying to
please everyone a long [__] time ago
and I just like making them the way I
like making them people want to watch
that's cool and people don't I just love
the Jerry call out
oh I've had that cooking the entire time
I mean do you feel that it's do you care
if anyone watches it like 1.25 or 1.5 or
is it just oh not really like [__]
life's hard dude
no the creative Integrity the timing
it's not every video I do though it's
only the long ones but no I mean like
look if if my videos provide any [__]
enjoyment to someone enjoy them however
you want yeah all the way through all
right guys
I'm like this guy yeah
you know you know which one I just
certainly remember which one it was um
it was the one where you talked about a
horror manga with a girl or something
and someone dies
yeah and I was like this sounds [__]
sick I'm gonna read it I just didn't
and every single time I think about
reading it and I I I like man I can't
click I can't keep clicking on this
video and clicking off it this is
psychotic YouTube's gonna think I hate
this video uh so yeah I've got to read
it I will I will
and for some reason I just haven't read
it uh I guess the next time you come on
the show I will make sure I've read it
yeah I promise I just have to click on
and off your videos yeah so I'm gonna
I'm gonna try and not do that as much
um yeah you're killing me here Connor I
I think I've I I YouTube though will
automatically put and I don't know why
it does this for me it'll it'll keep
replaying your goddamn liminal Space
video for me like like I will leave my
YouTube on the side and then two hours
later whenever I've left it for some
reason I'm back in I'm an hour into
liminal space I'm like man
it constantly recommends me my own
videos my reaction is always like oh
[__] God I hate this guy I just don't
understand why it keeps recommending me
this one video like like I'm obsessed
with I don't even I don't even watch
anything about living or spaces I've
never watched it well how would you know
if you don't like it if you haven't
watched it no I've seen it but I clearly
don't search out for it or click on many
of the videos for some reason your
goddamn video keeps getting order Auto
played for me I click off two minutes in
I keep telling it this video is not for
me
but I I did that for like some someone
else as well and it kept replaying the
like a h bomber guy Roblox video I don't
know why I would finish a video and it
would Auto Play that video and even I'd
watched it great video but it was um no
that's that's me uh like I think I've
talked about this briefly before that's
me and like I you should look out for
this I swear it does This I Swear
YouTube does this it'll keep
recommending it'll keep Auto playing one
video yeah so I fall asleep to like
certain videos uh and like recently it's
been like the history of the universe
where it's kind of like I've taught us
about this before uh I don't think I've
finished a single video because I
because they're about an hour long I get
20 minutes in and then I I'm asleep
there's so much mileage you got a one
video yeah
I'm like all right this time this time
I'll get further I get like 25 minutes
and then I'm like I don't remember
anything about the rest of the video so
one time I'm going to like finish a
video and know what the end of the story
is but until then and it's great it's
very very interesting content but also
it's just so good to sleep too yeah it's
so calming right yeah it's so calming
yeah but uh yeah John thank you very
much for coming on trash Guys a pleasure
genuinely yeah he flew from Ireland just
to come here yeah
no no it's a big deal when you come to
Japan you can come home again yeah yeah
happily no that'd be great yeah thank
you very much for coming to our show as
well yeah anything you want to shout out
um just sure uh you can find me on super
eyepatch wolf I also do like have all my
like streams on regular eye patch wolf
and uh iPad 12. iPatch wolves.com
if you're interested in a weird concept
that barely makes sense on a t-shirt
what a pitch
but yeah no thanks so much guys
it's been a long time coming we've been
we've all been close friends forever for
sure and I'm glad I got to gush about OG
Anthony for a while before it's uh
completely lost in the dark
but hey look at all these patrons though
John do you see all these patrons on
screen oh point to your favorite one oh
it's got to be this one what a scam
actually that seems like a good looking
bunch this is a Shen movie fan actually
yeah
well that's a bleach fan actually yeah
I'm sorry God damn but hey if you want
to support the show then head on over to
our patreon patreon.com trash taste also
follow us on Twitter send us some memes
on the subreddit and if you hit our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah
obviously go check out John's stuff
links in the description below
see you guys next week bye bye
[Music]